all right other sports news here on a
monday afternoon the vegas golden
knights they made headlines last week on
thursday trading for buffalo sabres
center jack eichel today eichel is here
in southern nevada he's here in las
vegas and spoke to the media for the
first time eight sports reporter kevin
martin was there live inside city
national arena kevin good afternoon
well good afternoon it's a huge day for
golden knights fans as you mentioned for
the first time here at city national
arena the newest golden knight jack
eichel addressed the las vegas media for
the first time in his introductory press
conference the center that was recently
acquired from buffalo brings all of the
star power that will fit perfectly with
the bright lights of las vegas
unfortunately medieval maniacs won't see
the 25 year old on the ice for at least
three months as he is scheduled to have
upcoming surgery on a herniated disc in
his neck in four days but he said in six
months he expects to feel 100 percent
back to normal and said he's excited to
be here in vegas and be a golden knight
i think the first the first 24 hours was
pretty overwhelming just a lot of a lot
of things kind of go on
internally a lot of emotions and but
it's nice to get out to vegas it's nice
to be here it's nice to be at the
facility everything's so top-notch here
and just the communication from people
so far has been
has been great so um
yeah very excited and it's been it's
been a whirlwind
[Music]
the former number two overall pick and
2015 nhl entry draft has not played
since march 7th that's 246 days ago he
scored 18 points in 21 games last season
for the sabres and jack went on to talk
about what else he's excited to be in
vegas for off of the ice and he grew up
in massachusetts went to school in
boston of course played his first six
seasons in the nhl in buffalo all very
cold climates that of course get a lot
of snow so he's thrilled that he is in
hot sunny las vegas and doesn't have to
deal with the snow anymore he ended his
press conference by saying there's no
place he'd rather be reporting live at
city national arena kevin martin 8
sports now